Oh,
I was wondering if you could,
if it's plausible,
it's race and our narcan
tipple or narrative origin
for some of the intellectual
tenants of the postmodern as oppose to
like deny the structures of language as
corresponds to reality.
Uh,
deny the sanctity of the individual.
I think you've done some of that in your,
your talk today,
but you think it's possible from a
psychological perspective to trace kind of
the narrative,
um,
origin of postmodernism and human
behavior or is it so unnatural?
No,
no,
no.
It's an architect,
an architect.
I mean there's always,
there's always a force so to speak that
opposes the logo's hallways that that's
the hostile brothers.
It's a classic archetipal story.
There's always Cain and Abel.
There's always hostility between the
two primary modes of operating in the
world.
So,
and this is the,
this is the modern manifestation of that.
And it's partly,
it's partly a good thing in some
sense because it's useful to be deeply
challenged.
It's good to have an enemy
because the enemy makes you think,
the enemy tells you things
that no one else will tell you.
It's the [inaudible].
It's an advert adverse.
It's an ad.
It's the adversary that that that that
stops you from being merely inert and so
postmodernism plays that role.
It's,
it's extraordinarily critical but,
but things can go too far and and,
and the motives and things can go too far.
When they go too far,
they reverse.
That's what happens and hopefully
they're reversing now hopefully
as being mainly
we seem to be seeing something that has
a different form today that might be,
is more associated with the feminine.
Can you speak to that and also what is
the nature of its power over men that it
seems to be able to silence us.
Okay,
so the question is that the totalitarian
forms that we've seen primarily in the
past have been male and,
but maybe we're seeing
something different now.
I really don't think it's different.
I think it's,
it's other common kind that's
expanded in its dominion.
So you imagine that there is an essential
feminine pathology just as there is an
essential masculine pathology and the
essential feminine Pathology Freud mapped
out.
It's the oedipal mother and
the mother is the mother.
That gets too close to her children.
Right.
And intermingles herself with them too,
too great a degree that in her attempts
to protect them undermines them fatally.
And so there's a classic representation
of the feminine in the West and the
classic representation is married.
And here,
here's one of the representations.
It's lovely and it's derived at least
in part from the story of Mary and the
snake in the garden of Eden.
And so Mary has her foot on a serpent
and she's holding Christ off to the side
like this.
Well that's exactly what
mothers have always done.
It's a biological portrait of human women
is they hold their infants out of the
reach of the terrible Serpentine Predator.
Obviously that's what we do.
Well that's fine,
but adults aren't infants
and neither are children.
And if you treat them like they are,
you undermine them.
Ew,
ew,
ew.
Pathologize them.
You turn them into old infants.
That's an ugly thing.
And that's the Friday in nightmare.
You know,
in,
in this happens in
therapy very frequently.
I mean,
you can be tangled into a terrible
relationship with your father.
That's often either because he was absent,
abusive or tyrannical,
something like that.
But that the standard pathology with
mom is she did everything for you.
Well,
what's left for you to do
nothing including never leaving.
Right.
And that's the motivation.
You know,
for the woman who's nothing
but protective mother,
there's no role outside of nurturing,
of nurturing,
nurturing,
of nurture,
and of infants,
of nurturer,
of infants.
Well,
you just keep them infants.
They'll never leave.
Am I kill you in night in your sleep?
But they'll never leave.
Sure,
sure.
I mean,
it's so comical watching the feminists
postmodernist in particular rattle on
about the absence of gender reality and
act out the archetipal devouring mother
at exactly the same time for them.
For them,
the world is divided into predators and
infants and the predators are evil and
need to be stopped and the
infants need to be cared for.
Well,
that's what the mother does,
but adults are not infants
and all you do is destroy them
when you treat them that way,
especially when they're adolescents
and just starting to develop,
you know there's,
there's a rule that I attempted to abide
by when I had small children and the
rule was don't do anything for your
children that they can do themselves.
And it's annoying that rule because
it takes you like 15 seconds to,
to dress a two year old,
but you let the two
year old dress himself.
It's like it's 15 minutes or
20 minutes or half an hour.
You chase them around the house.
But if you let them learn
to dress themselves,
then you don't have to
dress themselves any.
Do you address them anymore and they can
do it and you do that with setting the
table and you do that with everything.
It's like,
no,
it's okay.
You do that now while
I care for you so much.
Let me do that for you.
It's like I don't care for you at all
when I say that I don't care for you at
all.
I'm going to stop doing everything I
possibly can for you as rapidly as I
possibly can say.
Well that's great.
That's how you work in an old age home.
Do not do anything for the inhabitants
that they can do themselves cause you rob
them of the last vestiges
of their independence.
Right?
It's what you do when you're a manager.
If you're a good manager,
you make yourself Sir perf Lewis by
extending autonomy and independence to the
people that you manage so that
they can take over the whole job.
You don't do that by doing everything for
people and you certainly don't do that
by dividing the world archetipal
Lee and uncritically into predators.
Those who have more and victims,
infants,
those who have nothing and acting like
all you can ever do is protect them.
You don't protect,
first of all,
you can't protect people.
You can only make them strong.
That's it.
You cannot protect them.
You can make them strong and
then they can protect themselves,
but then they don't need you.
Right,
and there's the underground pathological
element of the devouring mother.
It's like,
never leave me.
Here's the deal.
I'll do everything for you.
You just never leave.
Right.
That's sleeping with your mother,
right?
That's the Friday at nightmare.
Right?
You don't invite your child into your bed.
Right.
You distinguish between them and you,
you distinguished between them and
your husband and you facilitate their
independence.
A part of the reason why it's useful to
have a mother and a father is because
the mother has to fall insanely in love
with the infant or she throwed out the
window.
Right?
Because they're,
they're insanely demanding
and they're always right.
Right?
Because the right way to treat an infant,
especially before nine months,
is I'll do everything for you and
you're always right in your needs.
Take priority over everyone's one else's.
And anybody that
threatens you is terrible.
Exactly right.
But after,
you know,
once the kid is ambulatory and
starting to be independent,
that's the wrong attitude.
The attitude then is no,
get the hell on with it.
And men who are less prone to negative
emotion and less compassionate are much
better at fostering that
kind of independence.
And so it's usually then when they step
into the family and start playing with
the kids rough and tumble play and
pushing them forward and saying,
you know,
get on with it.
You can do it,
you can do it.
And it's very hard for a mother to play
both those roles because she has to
fall.
So in love with her infant that it's
difficult for her to be universal care
giver and disciplinary.
And at the same time,
you know,
cause the roles or the roles
run contrary to one another.
So now women have entered the political
sphere right on Mohs and so they're
going to bring their essential nature
with them all the while saying there's no
such thing as essential nature.
It's like,
yeah,
there is.